all right so this is the real you I just
got the segue good for me all right I
really don't you know my mind's always
so all over the place it's like it's not
I say the tide of like please my kid go
on every day I don't know it's I'm not
convinced I necessarily do I think it's
some sort of emergency backup in my
brain it's just like you know up no he's
dead okay just keep the body moving and
talking what will fake it anyway okay so
we got the real you
this is an episode where Finn makes a
sculpture out of his saliva which is
hilarious
for bubblegum but then she accidentally
sneezes out it's gone
so hey what's going on give me three
more hours so he wants to come up with
something for her science barbecue which
apparently a lot of like computers and
calculators show up to which I was
really clever and and he goes to visit
choose goose or juice shoes CH like
choose like you're joking
okay I think last time I said juice
goose not J EWS I thought was like juice
like you know drinking juice don't
encourage him anymore
what's all the Jews I will love juice do
you have any juice not for you go get
some juice juice n' juice juice enough
oh my god okay so and before that he
tries to learn stuff from these worms
another very funny scene and awesome
thank you that is lovely I'm gonna hey
he got for me that was a present from
Jason you are Johnny goose so you cannot
have it is that the rule now only
probably geese can have
and I'm not spanking you either that's
good you are the worst I'm either gonna
get some juice or a spanking by the end
of this okay or if not I'm gonna want
triple the juice goose in the next
episode cuz the naked ladies didn't
happen in this one choose I'm gonna I
what has they change to juice goose you
know cuz I got my way the last one I got
triple the butts so I'm gonna see if I
can get a juice cos maybe choose goose
is brother or sister juice juice juice
who is Jewish and it'll be great be a
Jew juice juice good God you know really
sidetracked but to be fair this episode
Canada's two like with the worms thing
it's like you could cut that out and not
miss anything
Oh hilarious yeah and though whatever
problem a teacher has with what wasn't
werewolf Queen with that one and I love
evil raining blood
well mcscreamy let's see we'll see about
that
oh you aren't here as a student that
hasn't been there like the whole year so
that's all great and then he's given
these glasses that make him super smart
and he becomes so smart that he rigs it
so that bubble gum saves the day which
was somehow win her over and it does
somehow and they live happily ever after
I suppose so the only thing that really
confused man oh it sounds strange but
the only thing that really confused me
is that wasn't there an episode where
they kind of went on a date already so
like you remember he had to woo her
together yeah so it's like it was yeah
that's what I think so so why
why did YC have to kind of woo her again
does he just sort of forget about it or
not like a real thing or not a real
thing do you after you first dated your
wife I mean did you just say oh great
you went on a date with me awesome we're
done
no no not that knowing no but I mean
like make it sound like you know he's
afraid to talk to it like they're not
even a couple or an item or dating or a
they at least it's not acknowledged you
know just cuz you laughing at did you
see you like each other doesn't mean
that all of a sudden I mean I think okay
I suppose Oh our girls like you know ten
steps ahead on the show like you're
supposed to hear like it's like they
have the marriage the wedding planned
and everything
first of all bubblegum is a bitch she's
okay that was my everything
what is your hatred for Buffy I just
like and that's like I just don't like
her so I'm like her
no maybe she's stringing him luck maybe
she doesn't like him that way and so
when she told him before oh then I like
you well I mean there's you know there's
a two-way interpretation there it could
just be I like you as a friend she
doesn't want to tell him yeah that's why
I was wondering I was thinking maybe
they were doing that right but it's like
how how could you confuse that it was
like the table and the romantic music
didn't even say like I'm trying to woo
you or this one this one got hit on by a
chick and didn't even know it and then
hit right here buddy we are looking for
old are you questioning her oh no
because she knows she should know this
stuff because like I said with women
China yes
like I said they know all this stuff
they always like pop up on these things
like you know as soon as I say like it's
like there is no like in girl language
that just means like it means like
interest women are crazy
every single one a gigantic stereotype
all of you no exceptions at all I've
seen every single woman in the world
sorry oh sorry and they can't push
either so Jordan can't say she likes you
not like wow this is like the most
surreal v-log readout
we got farting we got like stuff that
she digs back to those yes it was so
that shit yeah the charity yeah that
cheer smells pretty bad right now
it's kind of spreading over in this way
just say and it's if you want to keep
that chair under control so okay okay
one more segue into nothing has anything
to do with anything but a lot of people
in the commercial comments were like I
am very insulted I'm a goose you know I
got very insulted when you said that you
know men don't catch on to you know
being hit at and stuff like then they
won't play how dare you instead I'm a
man and we meant don't have it easy you
know that and like I get it's it's a
friggin joke and I know somebody guys
and I'm clearly one of those guys who
can get hit on and just have no clue he
had to run back and apologize to the
poor girl and say I'm really sorry but
I'm actually married yeah I mean it's
nothing I I think that is and whatever I
say it's like a guy fed a or a woman
thing or something like that doesn't
mean every single guy every single woman
I mean obviously not it's just like what
have you ever seen it I mean but that
there is like you know metamath away
with norm a certain way and there are
patterns I gravitate towards it too but
if you're not or you do something else
fine doesn't matter
go ahead leave with your vagina happily
so back with the episode
good diffident narrative it's not a shot
again
you saw me just like trying to creep in
and like whatever I waved my arms he's
like God there he goes sorry okay it's
all behind the scenes stuff in this one
then you're not privy to stay sinking
down video games or something nice
spank okay no okay yeah you guys are
getting completely off subjects big
freaking surprise that's God no one
thing that I really really like that you
apparently think should not have been
there I know I said you could cut it and
nothing would have been lost in terms of
the story but I still love that scene
it's a great scene tell us about the
ones don't fuck the worms George no I
liked that when there's when he sits
there any drugs on his finger and Jake
does the same he's like he's like oh you
can just shrink down so Jake shrinks
down you could just turn himself into a
word yeah I mean I've seen episodes of
other cartoons and other stuff where
like someone gets super intelligent and
everything well I like in this one where
he gets so intelligent he already knows
what's gonna happen in the future yeah
which i think is hilarious and then of
course I love the scene where he puts
the glasses on it goes into his head was
literally like loops through atoms and
molecules and odd stuff galaxies and all
the way back from an opposite angle to
his face again and then when he takes
him huh or when they're taking off it
goes in Reverse but then comes out of
there but yeah I thought that was really
very clever too I thought that's uh you
know I think like kids can watch it be
like oh like what did that mean how did
that it's like it would sort get a
biggie a little bit too and I think for
adults it's like you know just whoa
trippy man and they you know they love
the cast up too so I love just because
it's more introspective than trippy uh
what's with you and drugs yeah
problem you know you know if you watch
this show from there to the couch and
back down a jump on the table now he's
going free this game with your farts I'm
sorry bitch air dunk stop thinking about
drugs go outside get some sunshine in
winter in Chicago shining shines no it
doesn't go in the winter okay
okay finish this episode and we're gonna
okay I liked the episode I thought it
was interesting I like the direction it
went even though you people can't stay
on course it's bubblegum I don't even
know why I said it
PB is fine PB is finer Peebles later oh
yeah later nickname people's yeah Finn
comes with people's I like pebbles Thank
You Vienna Pelican thing that's weird
oh no I like I like PB I think she's a
fine character but this episode
introduced when a male type here will
not introduce but showed one of my
all-time favorite characters peppermint
Butler I love his voice
peppermint Butler is great that was I
think it's something like it one other
one does he come back more or is like
come back okay I was gonna say cuz it's
like if you did me like didn't do bad
March and the Tigers out but neither did
choose goose that cat is pissing me off
arms like this are we gonna move that
time breaking fuck is that okay
peppermint Butler I mean it wasn't
really funny Oh
oh that's a chair - okay I never had a
special and he's like yeah you give it
back when you cry pride for my cold dead
hands um no III felt like the whole
thing
I thought that too it really funny yeah
I know it's right because we're getting
so sidetracked stuff it's like going
really really funny when they are
getting sidetracked me as in I'm all of
us yes I'm going you too I like you hi
so what would that mean I don't know as
a male I would take it as friendship /
possible come on no you were like I like
you
well that's pure friendship right back
okay good gonna be anything else no I
know you're getting it yes Joey final
thoughts on the episode that's just
liking yeah I just lost my Peebles this
is a good character so so glad I brought
you on this one why bring so much to the
team oh but before we go why do you need
public am i I can't explain it I just I
guess my she irritates me because she's
supposed to be this sweet and cute and
great she just drives me crazy is that
she isn't though nobody sees it I know
exactly what it is because this happens
to women so women it seems naturally
dislike someone that they feel are
prettier than them oh my god whoa okay
okay no but I I'm God hi I am stay away
from that so Jory do you think Peebles
is prettier than you is that why you
have the instant dislike no because you
like lumpy Space Princess lumpy Space
Princess Jason
you don't know what you're getting
yourself into
it's not I actually don't think she's
pretty at all I think she drives me
crazy because everybody thinks she's so
sweet and so nice but she's not I see it
nobody else does
kind of like the hand that I see I don't
see anything
I don't exactly wait Doug's gone
Oh in kiss mm bye bye people